hello and welcome to this video debo
matata okay I think endo and welcome to
this video are the first words spoken
today the Senate early somewhat early
morning session even got a coffee yeah
so we got the decline to banco here or
let's say he took on b5 but then played
bc v6z vomitar says there better be a
video about this game ya know there will
be all there is ok here Bishop g4 is a
good move because I can get them can get
rid of this this Bishop um yeah I think
I even take there without being provoked
I like to have the the night gone so em
let's see I'm reasonably happy about
this here just wonder how to how to how
to play it in 98 c 7 is probably still
the right idea it's just I just wonder
if this was such a great move over here
on my part 98 6 7am usually I go Queen
d8 to cover is heaven in case of Bishop
g5 but this is not really possible here
maybe this move I know it is a bit slow
but I will be shipped g5 which was
hanging anyway so i don't know if that
was really the critical thing to do h6
it weakens a bit but ok i guess it is
not super important the way it turned
out i got this when do the going 97 I
like 95 to deform it would be a would be
ideal
okay so here the thing is i would like
to irritate him too inkay for fourth
with the development I can't even go
here right there's nothing wrong about
that I think makes a difficult time to
develop he might move the queen but I'm
not quite sure where I mean we'll see it
is an irritating piece on v3 anyway
maybe he can play the Queen victory to
all this one okay but 95 was on my
agenda anyway so do I mind this not much
I don't have now let's do this that's
good I hope and now yeah the question is
where where maybe b6 and maybe b6 tuck
the same can still not move the bishop
yeah he has to play some some
contortionists move if this is the word
yeah be to where I'm attacking it four
times and he defends it three times so
this is going to be critical yeah this
is a good thing about this opening about
the bangko if it works well it really
works well yeah you get a an absolutely
a great position at least I think this
was great if i'm not totally owned yeah
well okay i know here right hmm he's got
like I wonder mmm Group B 5 Bishop d3 is
somewhat problematic
I cannot take their yeah that is that is
a possibility but then then I can
actually go yeah it really is ok anyway
now I was thinking see for ya one night
be five actually night be five and then
Bishop did too hmmmm I wonder c4 opens
it up completely yeah come on let's do
it I mean b3 is weak and this is a
reason not to trade it but now every
every piece comes in as active as
possible ok um something here let's not
that great probably I probably played it
a little bit too simplistic push-ups III
and this Bishop be six actually hmm not
good
hmm that didn't go too well especially
considering how good the position walls
ok Claud still it's still a game can I
do something else probably not yeah hi
Bonnie this I can actually try to play
because of his weak horns the minute the
clock situation with the minute and down
this problem or down to the being down
to a minute it's the correct way to
phrase it this is it this is the thing
here but I want the pawn right how is he
not losing it now I have Bishop f6
Andrew t5 if he attacks the e7 so I'm
going to win this pawn at the end let's
see a tenth lecture correct his pawn
structure possible ok so let's do this
if he goes f3 he is getting a jeep own
but I have two connected passes even
though I know they don't they don't run
all that fast that will be difficult ok
yeah probably a bit too difficult
check Oh No ah shoot i forgot about
Bishop g5 I was just thinking I have the
check but that doesn't do much I was
stupid can you play I mean as stupid as
I'm playing prolly this is how stupid
you can play hmm cap cap yeah we'll play
this on time probably I mean that he has
it he's a bishop up so it is it is a
draw of course theoretically speaking
with this is not nothing easy to do and
he's got more time yeah so if it's a
that's a very stupid blunder at the end
check check black forfeit and blundered
the bishop there that is completely
unnecessary okay so i probably should
have gotten it much earlier ok let's
start the engine I mean white was
completely on the ropes here so she'll
cook b5 look before engine degrees with
with all these decisions ok Wow book
takes be three and then 93a let's strong
it's a very strong idea Wow whatever
that say that that's fantastic Forks
here well okay that winds probably
straight away if through p3 is the move
yeah picking up
metal material him okay so that was a
relatively clean one yeah the engine
doesn't like this move I kind of
suspected that but I was also thinking
that we made my pieces are very active
and he doesn't really feel that
coordinated but 93 really am yeah that's
it still seems okay now probably these
plants they have their board week so
probably this this cancels then they
cancel each other out maybe four equal
play and I feel the way it was played he
was even better some somewhere here it
might be better for wild Sixfields
somewhat tender but then can yeah then
decided to do the simple approach but
this is better now for me that that's
pretty pretty clear I'm kind of
surprised that the engine believes that
this is equal YS is equal it does he get
the pawn or then I just I don't quite
understand he gets the porn huh yeah
okay he gets to the pawn if i go here
you're always sg4 like this this is god
oopsies gotcha form or maybe all this is
also possible here because my energy for
I cannot talk about go down so root b 6
is actually strong I mean okay if i go
here then it's not this this and f3 is
supposed to be equal maybe because of a
5 yeah if i take and go here as if I've
yes this is actually losing so i have to
take here here just probably going to be
a drawn okay so i didn't really have
anything here but after this i got the
pawn and yeah i don't know if i should
win probably objectively speaking i
should like in a tournament game i think
black should probably win but hmm group
d 354 this is probably a little bit that
that's not good technical play Crowley
I didn't didn't see how how tricky this
becomes yeah yeah I was totally relying
on on the check from from f1 and
assembly I simply forgot that that here
i'm not i'm not taking of sorry that I'm
not taking the bishop so that was
suppose a stupid mistake I don't want to
go back here obviously this is a sick I
mean that would be a really funny way to
play at his school bag all the way may I
have to now but that's why the my
previous play was bad okay this is a
draw objectively but I'm still have to
do it and with the time I'm of course
just losing and losing by time yeah that
was a pretty pretty pretty stupid laws
and a gift character a little bit giving
away the bishop in the inner and ending
with rougane bishop yeah ok guys thanks
for watching